Aaron one of the aspects of this
incredibly elegant screenplay is how you
do not make steve jobs either a savior
or a demon let's talk about a little bit
how the how the process went for you of
what you set out to do when you started
to type out the script you know before i
knew what i was going to do what i
wanted to do I knew what I didn't want
to do and that was write a biopic the
traditional cradle-to-grave
structure and you touch on the
character's greatest hits along the way
this is structure that's familiar to
audiences and I just didn't think I'd be
able to shake it I didn't think I'd be
able to do a good job at it so I spent a
lot of time climbing the walls and but
also meeting with the real people who
were represented by characters in the
movie as well as several dozen other
people Lisa was really my way into the
whole thing as for the you know he's not
a saint and he's not a demon I think
that when you're writing a character
like this you you you can't judge the
character I kind of liked to write the
character as if they're making their
case to God why they should be allowed
into heaven and to do that I have to
find the things about the character that
I can identify with that are like myself
anyway I came up with this unusual idea
because I like claustrophobic spaces
because I like compressed periods of
time with a ticking clock and because I
like behind-the-scenes things and in
this case literally being behind the
scenes that there might be a way to tell
this story in just three scenes just
three real time scenes each taking place
backstage and the moments leading up to
the product launch but even if I were to
write a good screenplay it was going to
take a true visual master to tim-tim to
make hit a movie we could we could sit
through and also somebody who was able
to get
great performances out of some of the
world's greatest actors none of those
directors were available but Danny was
you didn't see that coming at all did a
visual signature for this script in this
work kind of you know come upon you as
you were approaching it you send the
access of scripts and they're just like
I think very similar to the reaction I
had a wish was it's dazzling and it
seemed incredibly kind of provocative
technically for us to kind of feel can
you can you add to this because it's so
enormous within this space you know it's
like 185 pages of dialogue what can you
do it's got its you're not gonna sit
there for longer than two hours probably
we always had that thing didn't ways we
wanted it to be two hours so were you
and of course once you get your head
round that it's actually very liberating
because of course you can that you bring
you bring these guys to it really and
and the job was to try and the drop what
we all said is you've got a quick I mean
you've got a clear a path for great
writing which it clearly is and then
even more important great acting but you
can embellish that path you know you can
paint it you can mess with it you can
have great fun with it as they slide
down it as they you know so that's what
we try to do really and I think it had
enormous hearts because you can read it
on the one level about being this
extraordinary man all of whom we have a
relationship with through his products
or through his mouth or through store
whatever but it's also about fathers and
daughters and I've got two daughters and
I have to say I was moved beyond belief
about that that scheme within it really
and I hope in my own life I haven't
behaved quite as abruptly as he has but
I've also know that some of the things
that were going on you've you know if
you've had a career that's had you know
you've been busy then you've made
sacrifices and they're not not
necessarily noble ones either and so
there's a personal sort of thing in it
you know you do you put yourself in it
don't you you try to and there's loads
of Michael in it of Michael in it and
in Johanna and Jeff and Scully is that's
what you get with great acting they give
you a bit of themselves was there a
specific danger or something that you
you really wanted to hit in each of the
three acts that Aaron wrote I just
wanted to remember my lines like just
learn the lines darling you know there
are so many of them you guys rehearsed
and blocked out obviously in in sequence
correct yeah you know again you know
Danny is just such a wonderful you know
inspiration unsaid and he everything is
there to facilitate the actors he's all
about the actors I mean he sort of says
he doesn't have an idea how something
goes but you know he does he's sort of
you know he pretends that he doesn't but
he's got clear sort of visions how he's
going visually you know how he's gonna
put energy behind the camera but he does
everything to facilitate us and you know
at times you know I was giving him a
hard time he was just so patient with me
he would always just smile and sort of
turn around I was like god when's this
guy gonna get angry with me he never did
and you know but what he really you know
set out was he works with you know you
can tell that directors that loved
actors and and he's definitely one of
those so you know that the setting up
two-week rehearsal period filmed the
first block another two weeks film the
second block and another two weeks I
mean that was crucial for me just to you
know to get the lines and tip for all of
us to sort of really you know just riff
off each other and you know again
working with the cast like this it's
just you're spoiled the writing I mean
it's you know when I got the script I
was like how did this land on my lap and
why do those two other guys turn this
[ __ ] down
you know so much so that I actually rang
Christian Bale up and I was like what
are you doing why are you look so much
more like him than I do and so you know
all those elements together I was just
yes it was I was terrified you know
again these guys were you know obviously
Danny was you know hugely supportive and
and really you know always positive
always energetic but these guys as well
really you know have my back from the
beginning I have to say and it's
interesting when Danny and I met to talk
about the film it was in Melbourne where
I was doing something else at the time
and Danny very kindly came paid me a
visit and we had a seven o'clock in the
morning breakfast meeting and and we
only had an hour cuz I had to go and do
some filming later that day and and I
just became aware that we was we were
chatting about the script and various
different ings and it was a wonderful
conversation but I suddenly thought that
time's running out and it okay right
listen listen listen here's what I will
do I will be your rock and I will have
Michael's back that's all I can tell you
and the other thing I want to do is
completely disappear into this role no
bells and whistles no big fuss just I
just must not look nothing like me and
that's it that's it and I really felt
that that was my sort of mo really in in
in in playing her was to have this sort
of steady hand at Michael's back honey
not that you needed it no no but I would
worry about him I would I would think
how the hell is he actually doing this
because he was clearly finding his way
in rehearsals as we all were and the
amount of dialogue and I would say to
him on a Friday I'd say listen honestly
it's let me come over on Sunday I'll
cook your meal because he was shrinking
that was the other thing I'll cut your
meal let's just run the lights just
running he go no no no I'm thank you but
no I got my thing and and he was in his
zone and you know utterly
self-sufficient I mean just just getting
on with it you know and and and and
that's what we all you know that's what
we all did but very much led by Michael
I have to say Jeff the
reappearance of Scully throughout them
almost feels like Hamlet's ghost to me
there are very you know in the best way
there's a shadowy aspect to him there's
a father figure in us to him of course
he needed somebody to run that side of
the business because the ideas he had
were that big he was going to change the
world he knew it and and Scully bought
it genuinely bought it I think in a way
fell in love with the whole idea of
being around this younger version of
creativity this new generation and and
helping to guide it corporately you know
he was when we met him he was a
scholarly is a good guy that this is
what he does you know it's that Mitt
Romney world of start-up companies and
and all of that but this was more than
that this meant more than that he bought
the you know sugared water versus you
know changed the world he bought into
that and it was you know a Shakespearean
fall really and how it ended and and and
the betrayals both ways and it they
never reconciled they never did and when
I met him there was still some pain
there there really was and that was
because the relationship meant so much
not just what they were doing though
there is a very maternal side to the
real Joanna but I also want to say too
that when I spent time with Joanna which
I did do a lot
we were always quite careful the two of
us to talk about Joanna Hoffman the
character in the third person because
she said she said I just can't I just
can't see this is me it's too it's too
emotional is too it's it was something
very difficult for her to do so we we
sort of tried to keep it separate but
also there's been some play with the
truth of of the pattern of things she
actually worked for Steve actually less
time than the film suggests and in many
ways I also feel that Joanna and correct
me if I'm wrong but she's almost a
composite I think of several strong
women who were very present in Steve's
life and as I say she was sort of the
vessel I think to that softer side but
she you know she loved him is it as
Michael said before you know she she
really did become quite
theory when talking about him and I I
remember saying when we all met her
together remember saying what's so so
extraordinary to have to have someone to
copy you know to have your voice and to
have your thing and then she looked at
Michael in she went oh yeah you don't
have certain and she was suddenly struck
by the fact that we couldn't say that to
Michael and then it really took her
breath away and she was a she was also
reminded of a moment literally a couple
of days previously where she was just
going to get coffee and she thought that
she had seen Steve and she sort of
couldn't recover for the whole day from
just this moment of thinking that it was
just the back of him
so she really really did love him and I
I wanted to very much honor that and and
capture the the essence of that even
though it was a composite character in
many ways Aaron and Danny to wrap up the
one of the things that the film
obviously makes clear is how jobs have
helped people overcome a fear of
computers and in some ways the two of
you and Michael and everyone in this
film kind of brings jobs down from
ICONic size or God size back to man size
it really restores in some ways to human
angle to a figure that seems larger than
life would you agree with that
i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i I think that's
true and I think there's that's that's a
noble aim as well I think there's also a
I believe in I'd bang on about this
probably too much but I think there is a
juicy as well with these people and he's
done it previously in his previous film
social network and we I feel this film
is in a kind of lineage from there well
you have to these people are they shape
our world I mean there are easy words to
say but they're truly what they've done
in the last 20 30 40 years which is a
blink of an eye really is they turn the
whole world on its axis really with the
most precious thing we probably have
which is how we communicate with each
other and also this is political is what
you do with knowledge and how it is
available as he says imagine it's in
everyone's hands I'm a tiny um
and and and these companies have monitor
eyes dit as well as well as it being
visionary and very noble
they've monetized it and they need to be
dealt with constantly I think
governments are often I know this from
Britain they're often absolutely
petrified of them actually that because
they're desperate for them to bring the
prosperity they bring but so will
control them in terms of difficult
issues like data and you know personal
information and so these people need to
be answerable and I and I love the fact
that these kind of films are art will be
made and should be made and there is
resistance you know because these
corporations want to control their image
and they want to control information you
know and they say they don't but of
course they do
you know because then no the ones they
are the ones who are bigger than banks
bigger than oil companies bigger than
pharmaceutical companies the bigger than
countries even and you just and and I
think to be able to express the ideas of
them about them whether then whether
they're noble or not so noble is a
really important element we have to
protect and nurture and encourage anyway
well your question was did we take Steve
Jobs from God's eyes and bring him down
to human size and I have to say at least
when it comes to drama sappy as this may
be I think human size is better than
God's eyes I think human size is bigger
than than God's eyes I I'm not terribly
impressed with Zeus and Hercules and
those people they have that they were
born with a certain strength and super
power that they can use when a human
when a when you and I can can achieve
something I'll tell this very quickly
and then we'll be done because I know
we're out of time my father has never
been a sports fan but a while back I
don't know if any of you remember in one
of the many attempts that have been made
to bring soccer to America the most
sports crazed country in the world which
for some reason is not a fan of the most
popular sport
the world that my father was a lawyer
for a Time Warner his whole life
Time Warner bought the New York Cosmos
and they brought Pele in to play and my
father and I together watched on TV the
first televised game that pelé played in
in the US and again my father is not a
sports fan wasn't appreciating any of
this could not understand why anybody
would enjoy a game that's zero zero
after 80 minutes I'm sorry nil-nil
for the bridge and then suddenly Pele
jumped in the air inverted himself turn
himself upside down and did a scissor
kick
slamming the ball into the corner of the
goal at some ungodly speed and my father
started crying and he just said I had no
idea we could do that and III think that
that's what human size can do